et maintenant voici ce que miner série
samy naceri bon choix soit connaissent
et gérard darmon we go de sam scalia
voilà psychotiques au choco chico
palmito chicoty riche que tu perds la
superbe série c'est que ne plus je ne
vois rien de mieux
mais monsieur
hier bien voilà bruno gaccio vous
connaissez titre et serge raffy keller
bisang le public
les gentils c'est gentil c'est bien
c'est bien alors sa mine socialiste est
venu comment je suis venu en taxi
et voila voila je parie qu'il ya coffret
de taxi qui doit sortir aux alentours de
noël - l'intérieur aurait effectivement
bravo gonnot gassion en promo ya le
coffret 3 dvd la trilogie de taxi taxi
avec frédéric diefenthal marion
cotillard et mathieu bernard partie en
le premier réalisé par gérard pirès et
les deux et trois cents réalisés par
gérard krawczyk et les trois sont
produits par par luc besson
vous savez combien d'entre eux a fait le
premier taxi 6 millions le 2e 11
millions à peu près et le troisième 6
millions ouais mais ça fait bon bah ça
fait l'oseille s'est pas beaucoup
c
alors les moudre ont été rachetés
également par les états unis et le film
produit par luc besson est là et la fox
aura comme vedette à votre place queen
latifah femme extraordinaire que le
queen latifah reprenne le rôle de taille
de samy naceri voilà alors maintenant à
faire un petit quizz pour voir si vous
connaissez bien taxi samy on va vous
vous projetez les bandes annonces des
trois taxis et vous devez me dire le
plus rapidement possible à quel taxi sa
corrèze
non on va projeter les trois on va
projeter des extraits des trois bandes
annonces de taxi et la sortie vous lirez
dans quel ordre c'est est-ce que c'était
1 2 3 3 2 1 1 3 2 ou 2 3 1